In this video we'll look at how to add an extension in Burp Suite Enterprise.
The first step is to make sure you have the permissions needed to add extensions.
Only users with the Manage Extensions permission can add extensions to the library.
Initially this is only assigned to the built-in administrator role.
If granting this permission to additional users, keep in mind that during a scan extensions
run on your scanning machine with the permissions of the Burp Suite OS user.
Therefore there is a potential security risk if someone inadvertently uploads a fake extension
created by a malicious third party.
So to add a BAP, first download the BAP from the BAP Store.
You can filter the extensions by ones that are compatible with Enterprise to make this easier.
Log in to Burp Suite Enterprise.
Click on the cog to display the settings menu and choose extensions.
On the BAP extensions tab, click upload BAP.
Select the file you have just downloaded from the BAP Store.
And the extension will now form part of your library and can be applied to specific sites.
If you need to add a custom extension, after logging in to Burp Suite Enterprise, again go
to the settings extensions menu.
And on the custom extensions tab, click upload extension.
Select the JAR file for your extension and add a suitable name and description.
Click on the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link.
Thank you.